beaucoup de chance
j'ai trouvé un dea marche et le vélo en
libre service la solution pour se
déplacer en temps de grève
mais saviez vous que ce concept est né à
la rochelle en 1976 la peau vous allez
donner des vélos à vos concitoyens dans
les années 70 le maire de la rochelle a
le projet de vélo en libre service
gratuit 100 stations fixes où il a pêché
tout simplement inspiré de ce qu'on a pu
voir dans les aéroports vous savez vous
prenez acadie quand vous en avez besoin
vous le laisser là vous n'en avez plus
besoin on veut faire la même chose avec
les vélos un an plus tard en août 1976
la mairie mettait en circulation 250
vélos
ce week-end c'était donc le grand
lancement de cette opération dans une
ambiance de kermesse
un service gratuit reposant sur la
confiance que c'est lui ce député
cette expérience de gratuité qui est
intéressant la sérieuse de gratuité qui
prouve que l'on fait confiance aux
hommes
plutôt que de se méfier d'eux alors je
crois que ça c'est très important sur le
plan d'un changement de mentalité et
d'état d'esprit
si ça marche mais un an plus tard déjà
quelques critiques s'est retrouvé à plus
de 2 ou 3 circulation malgré ce constat
d'autres villes imite la rochelle à la
fin des années 70 châteauroux toulon ou
encore conflans sainte honorine avec son
député maire michel rocard qui testent
le service c'est la première fois que
vous essayez bien contente de l'idée
très bonne est beau c'est que ce sera
comme mode très bien et dans les années
80 la rochelle revoit sa copie
le système 100% libre service est
gratuit et modifié à l'époque 23 parcs
disséminés dans la ville
offrez 250 vélos hélas le nombre de vols
et de dégradations conduisait la ville a
lancé une deuxième opération baptisée
location gratuite
désormais les fameux vélos sont
centralisés dans deux parcs du centre
ville l'utilisation est gratuite pendant
trois heures les au delà les rochelais
doivent mettre la main au porte-monnaie
en 2010
le vélo jaune aujourd'hui à plier l'eau
existe encore un service public qui
dépend désormais de la communauté
d'agglomération de la ville la rochelle
restera la ville pilote pour les vélos
en libre service à paris
il a fallu attendre 2007 soit 31 ans
plus tard et un opérateur privé pour
profiter d'un service équivalent
[Musique]